here with reaction though is Missouri
Senator Josh Hawley who is also present
at today's classified briefing he's also
introducing a bill to require all social
media users to be at least 16 years of
age Senator good to have you uh I would
have loved to have been a fly on the
wall I'm dying to know uh are we
shooting down balloons are we shooting
down objects is there any chance that
E.T has arrived what happened you know
what's happening here
yeah you know the way things are going
Sean I think we might be better off in
this country if aliens ran the White
House sometimes I wonder if that is
what's happening listen they don't know
what they're doing they didn't they
didn't tell us they don't know what they
shut down they don't they haven't
recovered any of the objects that they
shut down these last three none of them
they haven't gotten any of them if they
have they told us otherwise today and as
far as I can tell Sean the only reason
that they're really shooting these
things down right now is they got
embarrassed by the fact that Joe Biden
let a Chinese spy balloon cross the
entire continental United States and
didn't do anything about it until it had
taken all the pictures that it wanted
that's what's really going on here there
is nobody who appears to be in control
or actually running the ship I don't
know where Joe Biden is or what he's
doing but he doesn't appear to be in
charge Senator you got to explain this
to me and I think the American people
have the same question is how do you
shoot something down but you don't know
what you shot at
great question Sean that's exactly the
question that was posed today in this
briefing that you just mentioned and
they don't have answers for that they
said they don't know how to when I say
they I mean the Pentagon I mean the
intelligence Community they say well we
don't know how to classify these things
they're not balloons but we're not sure
what they are which begs the question
then why are we shooting them down they
said they didn't think they posed any
hostile intent and I go back Sean to
what I said a second ago I think the
reason all of a sudden the
administration wants to shoot down
anything that flies is because they got
embarrassed they got caught lying to the
American people you know Joe Biden
didn't even know that this spy balloon
was over Alaska when it was over Alaska
they didn't tell him which goes back to
the question who's really running this
operation who's who's making the calls
doesn't appear to be Joe Biden well let
me ask you this if if they don't know
what they shot at and don't know what
they shot down how come they're also
saying on the other hand that it's
likely not from the Communist Chinese
they don't even know what they shot at
yeah exactly Sean they are all Every
Which Way on this none of their answers
make sense I came out of that briefing
thinking that nothing that they said
added up and so here's here's my
conclusion either they're lying to us
which is very possible considering that
they lied about the Chinese spy balloon
or they're totally and completely
incompetent or maybe it's both which
might be the most frightening
possibility of all but maybe the most
likely in either respect we are not
getting straight answers and you know
what Joe Biden could solve this he could
go on national TV he could level with
the American people and say here's what
we know here's what we did why we did it
but I don't think he'll do that Sean
because it's not clear to me that he's
actually making the decisions here I
don't know who's really in charge I
don't know where he is but he doesn't
appear to be the one calling the shots
what do you think that the intentions of
the Communist Chinese are to me it's
obviously nefarious uh it's it's a
pretty you know it's a it's an invasion
of our airspace I mean one has to wonder
what if they wanted to have a some type
of Bio attack on the U.S was this a
trial balloon no pun intended uh was
this uh perhaps a a test or a possible
uh EMP event down the line in the future
uh they're showing a lot of geopolitical
hostilities in The Straits of Taiwan as
we speak I mean what what were the
Chinese thinking here obviously they
don't have any fear of Joe Biden
yeah I think this is an attempt to
Rattle arcade Sean I do think that this
was basically them uh putting their
finger in our eye and telling us that
hey we can fly a a spy balloon right
over your country and there's nothing
you could do about it and that's the
that's the message that the
administration sent as well to the whole
world that the United States this
Administration will not act when they
know that there is a foreign object that
is spying on us in our own airspace but
you can't tell me this wasn't deliberate
you know even if the balloon even if the
Chinese didn't mean for the balloon to
get over the continental United States
and I don't buy that that's the case
Sean they certainly maneuvered it once
it was here right over the middle of the
country over my state over our military
installations they did all of that very
deliberately they knew that everybody
knew about it by that point and so that
is what they're trying to do here I
think is is show us that they can do it
and basically troll us they're trolling
Us in Joe Biden well and then of course
when our defense secretary reached out
to his counterpart in China and they
wouldn't take his call that spoke
volumes let's talk about this uh what
you would like to have an age limit as
it relates to social media tell us about
that
well here's the thing I think we ought
to say to these social media companies
Sean quit targeting our kids let's set
an age threshold 16. you got to be 16
before the social media companies can
let you open up an account before they
can go after you we ought to give
parents because I'm control here put
them back in the driver's seat I got
three kids you know parents all over the
country would love to know that these
companies cannot Target their children
cannot let them open up accounts until
they're 16 years of age let's protect
our kids when they're at their most
vulnerable well can't we do that through
the devices that they have if there are
certain controls parents have
you know Sean we can try that I can just
tell you you know I I don't think I'm a
stupid guy I'm not I'm not the smartest
guy in the world but my 10 year old he
already knows more about my phone than I
do and you know maybe that says more
about me than anybody else but I just
think it I just think it's hard for
parents to keep up and I think if the
rule was social media companies couldn't
let the kids on until they're 16 and
social media companies have to verify
the kid's age boy I think you'd help
parents a lot and the kids all right
Senator Hawley we appreciate you being
with us thank you hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else